i think there's two types of activities  there's the activities that we do  really enjoy doing that we can kind of  see ourselves doing for the rest of our  lives let's call this our permanent  activities and then there's the things  that we do in order to  get to something else let's call these  temporary activities i noticed that  things get a little murky as i started  getting paid for both of these  activities i think if you  really  want to make progress towards a happier  and like a more meaningful life  journaling regularly and like asking  yourself what you really want out of  life and like identifying these  permanent versus temporary activities it  can really help you figure out what you  need to double down on and what you need  to change  or at least work towards changing